hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's the time of the season we all love
the new battle bus is here let's look
through it together and see what we lack
and what we dislike if you want to help
me in the item shop when you get your
battle pass please write in a damaru ad
am a are you it really helps me out and
lets me make more fortnight videos than
ever before anyway let's do this it's
time we are here Season nine now look at
the newsflash screen it's thumb nice oh
I like it lads
look at that skin get that later right
Battle Royale let's do this okay
damn some good skins there said a Robot
Chicken it's literally a robot chicken
first Easter Egg of the year
so the bunkers did have a reason but are
we going forwards in time or back in
time
damnit I'd love to live there
[Music]
drop it you're reading is gonna drop it
right I need that minigame
[Music]
it's like you're eating a banana we are
in the future the Robot Chicken has come
to save us
aha
[Music]
which we're drinking his friend
okay
you John
[Music]
so the comedy skin is the guy with the
beard god
Jonesy with the beard I don't think
anyone predicted that is that double
axes need to back out we needed to watch
this through okay what we got rocks okay
well okay Wow all right I like this nice
opal opal it's good in orange and that
might be my new skin we have to collect
fought bites ship it tracer there isn't
she I wonder if we get a yellow version
of that that'll be good right and then
the Robot Chicken Sentinel Robot Chicken
right number two yeah rock love yes I'm
so happy with that that was the best
story ever I'll be rocking that
definitely we got to mark ho loading
screen nice here we go
we have a look at the different that
looks good yep I could rock that that is
a nice rap is rocks looking oil Super
Metroid II okay okay so legit harvesting
tools are now smaller and two of I can
get behind that does anybody actually
use those things I don't think they do
don't think that's a hint for anything
lori's lava hmm bit depressing for me
breyer went back they go up we'll go
back in time
[Music]
that's legit how fart sound on my
leather chair I've said too much
turbo spin okay that's not but not bad
indeed your airplane ha ha ripened
banana that's disgusting
it was like tiger print
[Music]
Jones ooh got a bone the field flyer to
the star on top not but can't miss this
girl 23 that's where we need to get to
then there's the comedy skin for the
season
it's got the banana sticker on his leg
he survived by eating a banana salmon is
hung I
I am bun and banana
I am banana whatever well that's nice
yeah I could get behind that one son
bird
all we have new pets I like the pets I
just don't like what they're on the too
bulky they should sit on your shoulder
on your left shoulder or something
now suppose you'd lose visibility doing
that
x marks the spot Vikings conquest so I
think something's going to happen there
at the happened
you can't look fullscreen at things LD
look bottom or screen
l3 for fullscreen it's also l3 for
replays cinematic yeah well done pod
light that's pretty nice
travursel chicken dance traversal so we
can do the robot chicken dance ready for
the memes next week everyone's just
going to do this for a full game so a
flying disc this season okay okay okay
okay more loading screen some bacon save
the world the bunker Basha so that's for
the whole ball scarlet strike ah man I
wish they'd reinvent these gliders
boring as hell
[Music]
that's a nice bit of wall art to tilted
plus neon for the new tilted hours
purple Creole pets Mikey or kayo
how the hell do you say that that's for
the ultimate trol the ultimate trol I'm
gonna play a whole game doing that after
every kill I will die a lot Vega
you looking good girl
[Music]
and she's got her own challenges bananas
banana bun and more loading screens a
violin here we go yes
this is my jam
it's a microphone microphone
I like the neon the neon looks damn nice
damn nice more rubbish more rubbish
banana sticker more rubbish splatter
that's good
nice nice yeah
ok sign-spinner
that's good yeah everyone will do that
at the end of the game victory I'll
ditch more load screens we have Ark
Mercy Me
[Music]
we have a flying disc Stratos be doom
with your hands okay dude whatever
floats your boat
rubbish another pet ginger one mine in
strike
retaliate er that looks good under the
load screen some are XP surrender flag
that could be useful the one you want
hit from death please don't kill me
pretty nice storm quite moves it
animates can you see it we have a bot
which is me their patrol we have the
lady from Deus Ex yeah that's deus ex
not today of sex as people think I say
with my accent des ex human revolution
plasma trails they look good or that
rubbish Marvy bucks neo world
we're in the matrix
this is Blade Runner this is Blade
Runner
there's a great film if you haven't seen
it
so modern steampunky and chef Adam just
in with it
oh no laid-back shuffle damn I like it I
like it a lot
power surge okay here we go
doc said to know Robot Chicken
transformers
it's very zone of Enders we've seen that
well is anything this Japanese really
isn't it
and then vendetta the upgrades
Sengoku mask okay
we're not but I don't really need to
unlock that one but I can see the appeal
green alt f9 okay okay okay okay we just
quickly I'm going to earn them so I got
my girl it's all that matters to me I
got my girl what do you think to the
battle bus anyway
so we have a new mini game so we have to
find all these pieces each week nice
next unlock in one day three hours okay
utopia mystery skin this season utopia
loads of challenges and on my word yeah
I still haven't finished the Ice King
from the season seven I've only just
unlocked looks last night let's start
with rocks what you got rocks oh I like
them I like them a lot
yeah so we've seen tried a lot so we got
the trace that comes in yellow then then
I've got my traces skin
[Music]
peace-out muffle
purple yeah oh she's got a damn skirt on
presume I can get rid of that I can wear
that yellow but with the top spandex D
stuff then I've got my trace of skin
okay yep looking forward to that one
Sentinel yet robot chicken wings
okay okay right comedy skin you get nice
axe and you get up and Hannah skip
because you ate banana you ate the Nana
it's messed you up
Vega that looks good not sure
very Tomb Raider
hmm that goes with the Robot Chicken
more status
I wonder what that does
they do win confirmed Demi nice the hell
is that look as long as you're happy
darling damn it you look good look at
that arm
solid snake Vendetta
so we've seen all those
rude it looks a lot like big hero 6
so what do you think I'm pretty happy
with Brock's that'sthat's probably my
favorite first skin you can get in the
battle bus ever yeah really light rocks
so I'm going to cane that one and get
that skin but I want it in yellow Oh
anyway thanks for watching it's been an
absolute pleasure if you like this and
like would be appreciated if you didn't
just tell me and I won't do it again you
don't have to put up with my ramblings
if you'd like to support meet my Cody's
Adam aru ad am a are you i hugely
appreciate all the help i get it helps
me make these videos so thank you very
much and I'll see you on the battlefield
I'm the guy with the pink guitar one day
I'll grow out of it see you soon
[Music]